miley cyrus or kristen bell i have
already thought about it
and haste was thinking ahead about what
actress she'd want to play her in a
biopic the interview comes not long
before anne tragically died after
suffering severe injuries in a car crash
the late actress opened up on david
yantif's behind the velvet rope podcast
about her list of dream stars to tell
her life story on screen if they were
gonna make a movie about your life you
know and they were going to cast you
know a young aunt like say you know at
the beginning of your career
any any actress come to mind miley cyrus
or kristen bell i've already thought
about it
marley miley cyrus or kristen bell and
if you're wondering why anne says for
miley it has to do with their similar
career paths
do you know why i feel that way
no
case in point they were both child stars
and played the dual role of vicky and
marley in the soap opera another world
which earned her a daytime emmy back in
1991.
you know i really want this to work out
for you
don't you i know and miley's breakout
role was on disney channel's hannah
montana about a teenage girl living a
double life as a pop star i think miley
is i mean she
first of all the fact that she did
hannah montana now i started as a young
actor i started at 12 supporting my
family the ability for her to be able to
pull up then i played twins
go on
i've seen her hannah montana to be able
to do that to be able to express that to
be able to be as bold as she's been
going from disney into wrecking ball the
way she moves the way she see her voice
her her compassion she loves everyone
she her ability to get out on stage and
sing acapella
that would be the way that i would see a
pure
pure artist engaging with the world with
the best time they could ever possibly
have that's why miley and as for kristen
bell ann saw her talent up close and
personal when the two starred as mother
and daughter in 2004's gracie's choice
ray i want you to come out and meet my
little sister gracie
what he knows i'm kidding anyway people
do think we look like sisters all the
time kristen bell
gave me my second emmy nomination she
and i played mother and daughter in a
lifetime movie
years ago kristen
again felt like a reflection to me her
ability to tell story do it through joy
do it with her personality charm
gorgeous timing and humor
um i see i i see myself a lot in her i
don't think it was any mistake that i
played her mom i wanted to play me when
it comes down to it we can see where
anne was going with her actress pics as
she thought both miley and kristen could
execute her humor and best portray her
journey in the industry when i think
about those stories and the journey that
i've gone through when they think of the
rock stars for me and i of course miley
is a rock star the two of them share a
um
a personality uh ability to to face the
world the way that i would want before
anne was taken off life support sunday
her rep released a statement on behalf
of anne's family telling e.t quote more
than her extraordinary talent she saw
spreading kindness and joy as her life's
work especially moving the needle for
acceptance of who you love we want an
opportunity in this world to be able to
talk about being together with human
beings so that we can engage in their
knowledge you know
and and hopefully grow as a society
because we do that
of course anne's larger than life
personality is hard to replicate but
it'd be nice to see if miley or kristen
are down to take on the role
you